so good to see you all again i'm so
excited for this time
every week um we get the opportunity
to chat to a wonderful scientist or
expert or conservationist
live somewhere in the world and we get
to chat about some of their awesome
research projects
and conservation programs going on and
today is no different
introducing myself i'm lizzie daley i'm
a biologist and your host
for today so thrilled to be bringing you
yet again another
wonderful guest all the way from belize
but before i do i should tell you
that if you're new around here this is
an incredible episode because we're
hoping to be bringing you
live manatees along with our guest who's
out on the boat today
currently in the beautiful red mangroves
and who's going to tell us all about his
fantastic work so lots to look forward
to and of course manatees i mean who
doesn't love manatees if you're like me
these mysterious
beautiful herbivorous sea creatures
that seem to float around mangroves and
channels are just fascinating
and the anti-antillean manatee is a
subspecies of manatee that
you may know and floating around the
waters in florida so we're going to be
learning more about
their biology the ecology and what our
guest is doing
to help protect the antillean manatee
and let me tell you
we have a fantastic guest um we are
going to be chatting today to
jamal galvez and he has dedicated his
life to manatee conservation
he's been working with manatees since he
was 11. he spends most of his days
going to find a manatee attracting a
manatee or helping protect
the waterways that they inhabit he has
many many different titles but he's a
conservation biologist he's a program
coordinator
for the belize manatee conservation
program um as well as a nat geo
fellow um arc um as well he he's done so
much this gentleman
and he's actually coming to us live
right now on a boat
in the middle of belize said jamal hello
give us a big wave and
tell us more about where you are it
looks beautiful
hello hello hello um thanks for having
me yes i am in belize in beautiful
belize i'm literally on the belize river
right now
uh one of the most cheering places this
year because when i do need fresh water
in order to survive
and they love the fresh cool water off
the belize river
so i am on a boat wow at the moment
this is an area that is known to have a
large population of manatee so we're
hoping that
1 or 20 may stop by so we can actually
get to see them today
and it's a it's a beautiful place where
you are and of course this is a place
where you've grown up i want to talk
more about the habitat and the
environment and why it's
important for these manatees here but i
guess i'd like to start by talking about
you and
what inspired you to get involved with
conserving these manatees in the first
place
for me i like to i like to refer to it
as my unusual walk to conservation
as a kid i grew up in a small village
just outside of belize city called gills
point
manatee ironically famous name for the
man in this presence there
so as a kid i always know about manatees
i've always see mantis but to me
they were just one and this is like a
bird or a cat or a dog they were just
there and
at that point and the injured men i
didn't know that they were in trouble
but as a kid i would see this weird
looking boat go by
my grandma's land and it said man to
research and i became curious and we
started asking questions and my cousins
and i would
we start playing on anti-rescue on the
lawn and we fight to see who get to
drive the boat or who gets to be the
doctor
but my my interest had outgrown my
grandma's lungs so i strolled them to
the dock where they leave and i
approached
the body pole and i said to him dr paul
can i come up with you guys and he's
like
ah kitty you're too small i'm not sure
if it was my i'm about to cry look that
made him see it
it's making me cry hello and i and i
went up today and i didn't even ask my
grandma's permission which had some
consequences when i got back home
i learned so much about these animals um
for me like i mentioned they were just
one another learning that they're
endangered and dangerous
endangered means that they're in trouble
and i felt as the kid of this village
who best done from than me to want to
protect and safeguard something that my
village represent my country represent
and i took the the honor of trying to be
a voice for the voiceless try to speak
for these animals who cannot speak for
themselves and
it wasn't planned i always i always
imagined becoming an attorney or a judge
but um now but nature and nature and
destiny had something else in store for
me and i'm very happy i'm privileged
honored to be a voice for these species
and i'm very happy to be here to share
with you guys today
best job in the world i think and um
just to kind of give a bit of context
because
it looks fabulous around you these how
many manatees
do you get say passing you by before we
actually went live there were manatees
um that went past typical isn't it
um but there's about what 2 500 manatees
left in the wild in these areas so tell
us
what do you expect when you're going
through these waterways and
and how many do you actually get to see
um this is one of the places in the
country that you you can almost
guarantee you're going to see manantis
why because
like i mentioned these are mammals
though they can
go between salt and brackish water salt
fresh and breakfast water they do need
fresh water to survive
so despite the distance they maybe
they'll come back to the mainland to get
fresh water
or maybe on a weekly basis so it's a
common place for them to come because it
provides very critical
resource for the species and hence it's
very important that we safeguard these
ecosystems so that these animals
can continue to survive um this like i
mentioned at the belize river
um it that not only has manantis it has
different species of
um fishes um we saw some girlfriends
coming in we saw some tarpons
many birds um beautiful red mangrove
that you can see hugging the shorelines
but it's it is a beautiful place um if i
was the one hanging out in here as well
fabulous i want to be there so badly i
know
for anyone that follows your amazing
work and all the things that you post
online they'll most likely see
um images of you with with very young
manatees these orphans
tell us more about how that comes about
and what your work entails there
well having another family is not not
our interest our goal is to keep an
artist in the world where they belong
for them to
live a wildlife and to grow up as a
manatee and to
our goal is to try and put measures in
place to ensure these animals do not
need to be protected
to ensure people understand that their
importance and people
becomes toured that the species want to
protect and safeguard these species
but unfortunately these incidents do
occur and suddenly
often as a result of human interaction
or human cause most of them are
anthropogenic causes
uh many manatees that we see that are
orphaned is normally as a result of
their mother being
killed um usually by boats there's some
other
activity that may have influenced the
animal to have become separated
but uh a calf manatee won't survive
without this mother these
animals these babies spend about two to
three years with their mom
and they become separated from their mom
at two to three weeks it's a loss
it's a last kiss and if we're not able
to successfully rescue these animals
they'll eventually die
um so it's very critical that we respond
to these incidents and we're very
dependent on the public to call these
incidents and to call
most of the times we'll get a call and
someone will say oh there's a baby
manager at my doctor in my canal or
in front of my yard really yeah
literally
literally because manatees at a young
age you tend to want to be next to
something
so they tend to go next to that next to
shoreline to something so that they can
feel safe and not
just out in the open and so we're
dependent on the public to call these
information and so we can respond to
these incidents
but too many things we've seen um have
become stranded
um when these incidents do happen when
these incidents do happen we will get
out our team will
our team would get out and we'll respond
to it like you're seeing in the video
right now
um this is a young craft that was that
was called in
that was swimming in circles um when
auntie's swimming in circles is usually
because of
their distress um
because so i'm right in my hands and i
picked it up
and i walked it on to the shoreline um
but while picking it up i have to ensure
it's very young very
fragile you don't want to squeeze it you
don't want to squish it too tight but
you want to hold it firm so it doesn't
hurt itself or you don't want it to fall
so i'm just i'm just taking it we're
taking it to our truck where we put it
on the truck to measure it to get a wait
so that we can send this information to
the rehabilitation center
so they know what to prepare a big pool
a small pool
an animal is very dehydrated and very
hungry because they have been separated
from its mother probably about two to
three days
it is more than two or three weeks old
um so
i'm administering some peria light to
try and rehydrate the animal as it's
very dehydrated
and the goal is to try and transport it
to the rehabilitation center as
quick as possible so that it can so that
it can get the care
that it critically needs and the long
term goal is to
eventually return this animal to the
world where it belongs
and for anyone watching this incredible
footage do get your questions in
to jamal live and we'll try and get
through some of those um throughout this
live because i'm sure many people have a
lot of questions i want to talk about
the biology of them
of manatees because that is also quite
fascinating and how they do
change from kind of fresh water but have
you found that
these rescues and and how you uh help
these manatees
has that changed over the years has that
increased at all
suddenly suddenly we're seeing an
increase in manatees that
are being injured it could be also as a
result of our large
vast public awareness people know who to
call people who are responding to
incidents social media has a large part
to play
in these incidents as well but the the
point is that we're seeing more mantis
which isn't a good thing one of the
other incidents that we're seeing that
are becoming concerning is that we are
seeing dolphins um
cause them and this to be strong they've
gotten reports of dolphins russian
leaving manatees dolphins separating
mothers and calves
you've seen calves come come in with um
with dolphin
dolphin scratches as if they're playing
with them we've documented
dolphin and the interaction so that's
another that's another problem that
animals are
facing and um over there over the years
we've been like i mentioned we've been
getting
too many calves coming i think there's
currently nine months at rehabilitation
center
that's a record number we've never have
muslim word not more than one or two
for the year but it's nine that's a lot
of money to feed a lot of money is
here for um it requires a lot of
attention as a young man until he's
required it's like a young baby
someone has to give it about two o'clock
in the morning four o'clock in the
morning
six every two hours it's a full-time job
rehabilitation center that does it um so
our goal is to keep an eye on this in a
while that they can drink free milk from
their mother and eat free sea grass
because it's expensive to rehab on
this and we don't want them in the rehab
we want them in the wild being wild
absolutely look we've got questions
firing it already i'm going to thread
them out throughout this live because
i'm also hoping that later on we may get
a glimpse of a manatee passing by
and but the first question yeah okay
let's have my i have my team on looking
i have my team looking out hoping that
we see something
i'll be sure to let you guys know please
do absolutely
um we just had a question coming how
many people are working with jamal there
so actually who's with you
show us who's with you on the boat if
you can
currently my team today is um who's one
of the program assistant i'm going for
guy
he's also our assistant as well um so
it's just three of us here
the team consists of three of us here in
belize but we
are we're all a part of the clearwater
marine aquarium um which is famously
known for the dolphin winter
posterity but we also do work in other
parts of the world including belize
um in cuba and other parts of the world
in belize
our our team is a member of three a
group of three of us
and we're working diligently we're very
dependent on the and the assistance of
volunteer
who assist us we can't do the work that
we do without the volunteers that we
have so i'm very grateful for the
support
and volunteers that we have which comes
in very many different forms from
come up from a three-year-old to a
seventy-year-old man
so yeah yeah all different farms
big efforts and i'm sure as your career
has gone on people get to know you and
your work which is so so important to
have that kind of stable
safe place for these manatees it's
absolutely fabulous um jamal you must
have so many stories can you tell us
like a unique
story or an encounter with a particular
manatee that's really stuck with you
ah one of the one of the most
interesting
incidents one of the most interesting
interactions i've ever had with amanda
is one of the first one on this that
i've ever um
i've ever been in in in direct contact
with was a rehab manager
by the name of woody that was in his
last phase of rehabilitation and i was
fortunate to have been able to get into
the got into the pool with the manager
which is very rare we don't
encourage people getting into the pool
with manatees that are
being rehabbers you don't want to
influence them you don't want to total
to change your behavior for them to
become too used to human beings
but i got in the pool on this one they
would literally swarm up to me and kind
of like put his slippers around me
almost as if i'm giving you a hug
but it was surprising thinking these
animals are here because of human
causes human traits but yet they still
find it within themselves to trust
us human beings and if it's showing me
love the worst thing that i can do is
just to hug it back and give it show it
that love because
these animals are a lot of in many
different ways so that's something that
i've stared at me something that i've
remembered i have tons of story but one
of the ones that i've
that that i felt moved me most it was
that interaction of woody
um what is a special moment to me and
it's always will always be other them
are special um
for me manatees are not they're not
they're individual they have unique
personalities
um do like to do this um twiggy likes
that
uh they're all unique and all especially
in their own way and has unique
behaviors so some people may look at
them as
f23 as a number but i look to them as an
individual
with a unique personality fantastic and
to get them
to get to know them on such a deep level
it's just so brilliant um i'm
fascinated by manatees they are as a
species you know
super interesting aren't they and an
order in a group so
firstly are they mostly solitary or do
they when they come to breed they form
these aggregations tell us a little bit
more about the biology humanities there
correct manatees are considered social
loners meaning that they don't really
bond they don't have bff they don't have
girlfriends my body my og
whatever term these guys are using this
i don't know
the only one that is normally between a
mother and a scalp and it's the most
critical abundance as a cough would not
survive without this mother
so we are always encouraging people to
avoid approaching mother on cars
whenever
you're out on a boat you don't want to
call them to separate um but
all the other times you'll see mananti
congregate is normally at a warm water
site
during the winter during the winter in
places like florida in belize when these
are more fortunate as we have
as women and this is warm all year round
so it's spring break for them in belize
all the time
it's cold but the only other place that
you'll see in congregate is common
places such as
um the river where they come to get
fresh water or a common sea grass but
where they're where they're feeding
and when they're made and which is the
only time that i can tell you manatees
are aggressive
it's like fighting it's like fighting
for a parking lot in new york city
someone moves the other one takes his
place and that's because i mean
it's pretty well you have 20 meals she's
not the one female and she doesn't get
to decide which meals she
meets with it's really really crazy but
very interesting as well
yeah i've i've had the joy of being face
to face with manatees in the water
um and it was just it was really
interesting to see how they behave how
they move
how they sleep do manatees sleep yeah i
know right you won't know how to sleep
if they need to come to the surface to
be
this is very unique as well and very
interesting um
if you if you sleep if you sleep like
i'm and you won't get enough rest
because you have to come up with
a few minutes to breathe it's very
interesting someone under the would um
rest at the surface
i guess those are the layers that raise
the guys because i don't want to go all
the way to the bottom
have to come back up to the surface to
breathe but if the rest of the surface
they only need to stick their head up to
green but someone else surface
restaurant will rest in the bottom
it varies depending on the individual as
well
okay fabulous and another question do
they have any predators where you
are predators volunteers don't have
any natural predators in belize the only
predator
manatees do have um sally's human beings
um
the main designer office are humans and
they don't have any
real trips in the world crocodiles won't
harm one ante
we've had incidents that has been bitten
by a shark but nothing
to be concerned about but mainly it's
just human activities that causes
animals to um
yeah so i do
at the at the end a little bit later on
i want to talk a little bit more about
you know
responsible behavior around manatees and
the impact of us on them because
obviously
it's such a big one um but out of
interest you know when i when you look
for whales you look for blows at the
surface when you look for
uh crocodiles you may look for you know
eyes or reflection what do you look for
in a manatee do you look for a floating
rock or something
you know some some people like to say
it's like a bowling ball in the water
because it has these two nostrils and it
kind of like if you put a bowling ball
in the water and if
it floats it all you'll see is just a
wrong surface with
two little holes um you also look for
swirls when i'm distant like the roll
they use their flipper a lot to move so
they make rolls in the water
but it varies in the morning they tend
to be very active you'll see them doing
barrel rolls sometimes
sometimes they'll do a tail kick
somewhere at the wheel but they're
they're interesting as well in in
regards to their behavior but normally
you look for something that
looks similar to a bowling ball sitting
in the water
perfect then easy easy to spot we just
had
another question come in a really nice
one actually um
how do manatees benefit the environment
around them and are there any special
things they do for their ecosystems and
you talked about them eating sea grass
so
how does it work current one of these
are herbivores they primarily feed on
sea grass they can feed and submerge and
emerge in vegetation sometimes you'll
see them sticking their head up
to grab a piece of mangrove as well but
um these animals indeed about nine to
ten percent dirty by the way daily so
they spend a lot of time feeding and
they're
and the other times they spend sleeping
someone on this eat sleep eat sleep
repeat
but um that makes them very critical to
our ecosystem as their own
hybrid summers within our waterways and
belize so they maintain the ecosystem in
the sense that because they eat so much
they excrete a lot they excretion acts
of acts as food
for crustaceans and and small fishes and
other other species within the within
the ecosystem
so they they manage to keep a balance in
the ecosystem and
people do eat fishes that also manages
an important role in
ensuring that the marine ecosystem is
stable
and is in good condition so
habitat's a really important thing to
consider as well in the conservation of
them
absolutely fascinating um quick check
have we had any manatees yet
nothing around so far we've got all our
eyes out in the water
no one understands we have all eyes on
the water currently
they're keeping us waiting for something
hoping that something stops by
but i'll see you guys one of them stop
by you're going to be first
we'll be there absolutely fabulous um
now let's talk a little bit more about
your
research um because it's not all kind of
being out in the field either is it
there's some work that you do with the
tracking and movements of manatees so
how does that work correct um
since 1997 we've been doing doing
research and management belize um
police had the longest longitudinal
study of these species in the world
so since 1997 even even following these
animals to better understanding to
the research is very critical as it
provides us with the information that is
necessary for us to
understand their movement understand
their behavior understand their
ecosystem need understanding how people
are impacting them
and based on this data that we're
calling is used to
to to inform conservation action whether
it's in whether it's implementing no
weight zones or both speed zones or
uh or designating a wildlife centre and
it varies in in many kind of ways um so
the way it works is that we actually
catch one on this to do a complete
health check on them
similar similar to when you go to the
doctor um the enemas the animal is
equipped with a tag as you see and as
you can see in the screen that
that that's the movement of one of the
managers that we've had
that must move around a lot so this gps
that we're able to
follow the animal to see where it goes
understand how it's interacting with the
environment and how it's interacting
with others
other species as well okay based on
based on this information we can we can
designate um
wildlife century um protected areas
and and all of those necessary things to
ensure that they're protected
and how far do they actually move i mean
is it over
big distances or is it largely led by
resources like food and breeding
it's very interesting as the females
tend to be more resident
residents pieces they tend to stay in
the system that we find them
while males on the other hand tend to be
more proper foots they tend to travel a
lot
normally looking for female and esters
so the meals travel long distance look
for female
when i was younger i was told about the
man until that was caught in belize that
went to mexico i thought he went to look
for tacos but
from what i understood he was he was
there looking for female that i was in
heat
but males do travel long distance with a
female
while the females used to be more
resident
absolutely fascinating um and how do you
go about
attaching a technology like that a tag
to a humanity i can't really imagine
where you where you place it
we have a we have a we have a specific
boat designed for it
and we have a well-trained team that
have been doing it for many many many
many years
um always animal health animal safety is
priority
um we're only taking this information as
it's critical for us to put measures in
place to
protect them um once it's on board we
have a
we have a tag which we attach to the
animal still this is a satellite tag
okay and basically it's normally
attached with a tether
and it goes around the tail of the
animal similar to a watch
and your hand this can float it does go
under it with the manatee it doesn't
prevent the animal's movement doesn't
prevent it from meeting it has been
tested and re-tested
you've seen animals meeting with it you
see animals do their normal behaviors
within
and this tag each has an individual
frequency similar to the radio if you
want to listen to pop you go to 96.5 you
want to listen to
the source you go to 105.9 so this
[Laughter]
i can track it on the computer via
satellite but i can also check in the
field
using using these um using these
equipments here
we have um this guy over there with uh
this which is an antenna
and a receiver so if you turn the
receiver on
you will you will hear you will hear the
tab start to transmit
does that even get complicated in thick
mangroves because obviously they kind of
go through very
very thick substrate sometimes correct
the target the tug is designed the
target is designed to
it's designed with a weak link that if
the alma does get caught or hung on
something
it will break it and break free so it
doesn't keep the animal attached it
doesn't harm the animal in a way it's
designed that way to ensure that animals
safe
it's also attached with corrodible
screws that in six months
the screws corrode in a south
environment and it comes off the animal
so it doesn't stay on an animal for more
than six months as well so there are
many safeguards in place to ensure that
i'm not safe during these times
and obviously you're learning really
fascinating things about their movements
and across different
um sexes as well which is just fantastic
more questions coming in um
uh we've got a fantastic one oh which
one to pick um
uh we talked about what manatees eat
should the greek this is a good one
should the green algae be cleaned
off the manatees so tell us what it is
first and why it's there
ah i'll just instagram and anticipate
because they're they're slow
they're trying to grow and wherever
things are when where where is the slow
moving if there's a it is a log in the
water algae is going to grow there
because it's not moving
when these suddenly don't move a lot and
so as you tend to grow on them
but it also depends on the environment
that they're in if they're in a broken
environment or they're in a saltwater
environment you may not see algae but
you may see
oysters on them because they're slow
moving
um it's not advised to remove it from
them um
especially in the world i don't think
you want so and it's probably definitely
legal for you to do so in the world
but in rehab sometimes they may clean
them to
administer medication or to administer
an injection or something of that sort
but it's not encouraged to remove it
it's natural it doesn't harm them in any
kind of way
um also it provides food for remoras
so it's okay it's it's a symbiotic
relationship with america
remoras manatees have algae and remoras
eat algae and so they are taking the
idea from the valentines and monetizers
are getting
so they already have their cleaners so
they don't need humans to clean them
they have their own keys and it's a slow
moving buffet for the remoras
brilliant um another great question
um okay so someone who's 17 is watching
hello everyone who is watching
and how are we able to help the
conservation humanities when i live so
far from them
i'm just 17. um all right
helping me on this there's no age
restriction age limit
there's no there's no criteria no
educational criteria you just have to
want
the most the most important thing is the
desire to want
to help i don't have to be here to help
sometimes people mistake helping with
always writing a check or donating but
you can assist by simply sharing a post
on social media
perhaps it gets to someone that that
that can assist in some sort of a way
it's basically telling the story today i
shared with you information about
manatees and beliefs that they're
endangered
now you're telling the story to someone
is the most critical way you can help
before you know it that story have gone
around the world so tell us
where the manager is from 17 years old
you can't help i started when i was 11.
there's never too old never too young
tomorrow is always a new day and always
always an opportunity to start over or
to start newer to begin something new
and it doesn't necessarily mean that
there's so much pieces in the world that
needs to be saved
find something where you live that needs
help that not a lot of people are
helping
is so much thing that needs to be saved
and not you know people that are helping
them so
i encourage you to find something within
your ear that you can assist with
totally agree being a voice is so
powerful and that's very much what
you're what you're doing as well
um being a voice
okay so these are antillean manatees
right so tell us a little bit about
there are subspecies
of the manatees in florida is that
correct
there are some species this is the
florida valente um similar i like you
can't really tell
by just looking at them okay so we're
looking at the little
there it is there it is so tell us about
what what you're seeing
jamal so i can see it just came barely
to the surface it's not fully out of the
water but i couldn't see
at the surface it's under the water
currently um in the river it is
sometimes it's very strong current and
these are lasers so the currents will be
pushing them back and forth
certain to want to come into these
places such as these coves where the
current
isn't as strong okay so they can hang
out here and relax and be peaceful
and not have and i have to be fighting
the current entire time
but in here the river is some some some
areas are more than 230 feet
but in this little cove there is very
shallow about four or five feet
so they can they can rest easily they
can feed among groves that are
overhanging
and it's generally quite in this little
area and would continue to come into the
small area here
yeah and you had a thunderstorm big big
weather yesterday does that
alter their behaviors do they tend to uh
tend to head into these coves more or
correct if it if it's very windy and
very strongly they tend to come into
this mangrove era that's why
we've always encouraged people to
protect mangrove
they're not just important for human
protection from hurricane and storms but
they also protect
they're also protection for wildlife
including manatees particularly
with calves calves are not able to
withstand high
wave action so mothers will tend to
bring their
the babies in here to shelter and bunker
down to to
start to be able to survive a heavy
storm or some
some sort of natural disaster such as
hurricanes though
okay are we on the move it looks like
we're on the move yeah we're just
drifting we're just we're just basically
drifting
i'm waiting for it to come back to the
surface and once it comes hopefully it
comes
up to the surface more closer so that i
can give you guys a breath
and uh it was an adult i'm guessing
could can you tell
the difference between a female and a
male it didn't look you can't tell
the difference between a female and a
male so oftentimes people will say oh
the monarchy is so cute
i don't encourage you to say that
because it might be a male and may not
want to be called cute
but um the only way you can tell amante
is
is if you can see the bottom of the
manatee the stomach area
the male genital opening is closer to
the midsection of the mouth
while the female genital opening is
closer to the tail that's the only way
you can tell if it's a male or female
because they don't see the wrong balls
on their head
and their heads yeah well i mean
i can't believe we have a manatee
somewhere in those waters that you're
looking at everybody there is a manatee
floating around live it doesn't get much
better than that now jamal
keep an eye out for that but i'm going
to talk a little bit more i want to talk
more about the um
the issues uh we you've touched on it
already you know habitat
degradation and collision with boats big
big issues
facing our manatees how much of a
problem is it in terms of their survival
long term as a species they are
endangered already but
i mean are you optimistic or
i'm i'm i'm always optimistic because i
feel like
there is hope uh if we lose hope then
there's no hope and then that's the last
resort
and we can i can i can't lose hope on a
species that i've committed my life to
i've committed to managing that i'm
going to ensure that they are protected
and
even if even if it means saving the last
one until that's here i'm going to be
here to do so
but um you're right saying that both
sides me and colin tamantis in belize um
it's concerning us beliefs has the
highest population of these cases in the
world
population estimate to be around 1 000
individual
but the rate racing continues to
increase every year
and fortunately majority of these bits
are as a result of watercraft collision
so we've been working very closely with
two operators both captains
and the likes of people that are
underwater the chance you can kill these
trips because it's very critical
for the survival of the species the
first saying that we only have a
thousand
and every year the numbers of debt goes
up it's definitely a need for concern
but i'm very hopeful i'm very optimistic
particularly because of the next
generation they're so excited about
conservation so excited to come out and
simon and is
so excited to come and volunteer and i
feel that they may be
able to to continue push continue to
work continue to
to ensure that manatees are safe and
released and that's one of my biggest
goal to ensure i can inspire the next
generation to want to be a part of
conservation they want to be a part of
change
so when that i no longer unable to do
this which i don't think there's ever an
end to it for me
there's no generation here to do it as
well the manatee man is the manatee man
for life
definitely
and um uh just talk about collision
specifically
i mean it was big uh as well when i
learned about manatees in florida and
and how you behave around manatees and
in those waters is super important
so can you just explain a little bit
more about what are the rules and
regulations that you're trying to push
for to make sure manatees don't get hit
by boats
sorry my land is is much easier for a
boat to avoid them
and entertain them and to have weather
but so what we do is to try and make it
easier for boats in the sense that our
research lead to
understanding of where the species is
where it's hanging out we're spending
time
and we de-mark these areas with signage
so that voters know okay
this is the manatee here i need to go
slow we try to do patrols to ensure that
they're they're they're adhering to
these scenes we put up psas
but whenever you're on a boat especially
in shallow areas
especially in charleston grass bed try
to go slow or to avoid shallow areas
because
if you're in a shallow water man and
this has no place to dive don't avoid
the boat
and if you know an area is known as the
manatee area going fast
in these areas doesn't help at all it's
encouraged to wear a polarized
sunglasses when you're on the water it
helps the glare so you can
see much clearer and it's encouraged
that
when you're in monetary areas to adhere
to voting regulations
that are put in place to ensure these
animals are safe
and if you do hit them and it's very
very critical that you reported
yeah reporting it might be the
difference in uh saving them and their
life
or having us come out and remove a dead
carcass um
absolutely it's about i guess having
just a respect that
you know you're in their environment and
and
they're not necessarily the fastest
moving species are they so really
in a boat with speed you have the upper
hand and fascinating
and really really important conservation
work um jamal we've got some more
questions coming in
obviously you're very passionate and i
think people are maybe picking up on
that so what made you interested in this
field and how did you find your passion
i wouldn't say i found my passion i
think about my passion for me
yes to become an attorney i always felt
that i was the man of the law
to be in a courtroom but um
learning about these animals and seeing
for the first time seeing them on until
the water i've never seen this other
water until i
until i started to volunteer seeing them
later so peaceful
so gentle but yet so peaceful and
understanding that these animals are in
trouble they're in danger they're afraid
something made me feel like i wish that
i had some sort of superhero board i can
put them up and put them somewhere safe
but i can't do that so i decided to
dedicate my life to try and put measures
in place to ensure they're protected
but not to protect my assistant but not
to necessarily protect them but to
create an environment where they don't
need to be protected
so that means changing people's behavior
changing people mentality towards
and some of the threats are you spoken
about particularly um you know the
protection of their habitat
obviously things are changing around the
world um
are the global threats to manatees the
same you know is a
loss of sea grass really going to impact
manatees on a global level
correct climate change is the biggest
trip to the world to even that's not
security
including valentines changing climate
change in temperature changing water
levels will definitely impact
sea grass let's see grass production and
that will impact manatees as well
trees and mothers similar there's kind
of fighting on our pill battle that we
have a lot of chips for human
and they have no choice yet so i think
if we can limit the among a trip that we
have that we can control as a result of
human
activity they have a longer surviving
chance but
it's not just climate change and boats
it's destruction of coastal habitat
people carrying young mangrove dredging
sea grass beds to build
mega cruise sports and marinas
destroying the very same environment
that we call home destroying the very
same environment that the animals need
to survive
things such as pollution plastic
pollution is critical to one of these as
well
plastic finds its way on the sea grass
beds and
these come up come by feeding then just
a piece of plastic they can die as well
fortune is a problem people do hunt men
it is the reason why they're endangered
in belize because they used to hunt them
in the past
it is not as bad as it used to be but
it's still present
and we have things such as entanglement
in fishing gears
are also a threat to one another in
belize so these animals are facing
many trips but the main trip currently
is the watercraft collision
which is something that we can change
and we can control so important work
a great question has just come in um and
you've talked about some of these really
kind of harrowing issues
but what are the difficulties in your
field um that's someone that's
something that someone's just asked i
think from me to you as well do you find
it really
difficult when you get to see you know a
manatee that's ingested plastic
it is hard it is hard but also i have to
ensure that i keep my composition i have
to keep the
the goal at hand i can i can
as much as i get emotionally entwined
with my relationship with
this and the individuals that we come
across i have to train
and to stay strong i have to ensure i
have the
the long-term goal at hand i've lost
someone anything but the goal is to save
the next five to ensure that the next
fire doesn't become that way
but is it's difficult for anyone to see
an animal
with its back literally opened up from a
watercraft
it is not the the most pleasant sight
and it's not the most encouraging sight
and it's sometimes they feel like i've
i've made some wrongs and then you take
you take five steps but i can't afford
to
to fall i can't afford to the rest i
can't afford to let go of the rope
because it means so much stride since
i've been since i'm 11 years old i've
seen so much positive
that has encouraged me to continue that
i can't make the negative
make me crumble or fall if i crumble and
fall
then the species combos and fall and
that's not what i want so i have you
have to be very strong-minded
dedicated and very
real absolutely every waking moment i
can imagine if you're thinking of
manatees
and so so would you say that's probably
some of the biggest difficulties
in what you do or there are lots of
practical issues as well
some of the practical um sometimes
majority of the stuff includes humans
so most of my most of my difficulty
is normally entwined amongst humans and
though we
go with encouraged and inspired many
people to change
there are individuals that are more
difficult to change their individuals
that may not see as important
and when you hit and speak to that it's
very depressing it's very discouraging
to know that there's a there's human
being that that do find hate
and as we always say we're not born with
hate people learn hate
and how can you hate an animal that have
done nothing to you how can you dislike
something that have
never harmed you in any way yeah yeah so
those are the things sometimes that are
that i feel that are barriers that are
hard to crack
but still i'm optimistic still i speak
to these people so i reach out to them i
don't avoid them
because it's it's easy for us to try and
convince the already convinced
preaching to the already converted no my
goal is to preach the ones that
that that are not converted don't
understand that are not
that don't see the importance so me i
spend a lot of time speaking to these
individuals that
feel that is not important because i
feel like if i can make this one
individual see
the difference and why they should
change i feel that i've gained some
critical growth
absolutely and and i think you are
making that change jamal we just had a
really good question come in
how can we help jamal is what they've
written so you are probably reaching
those people right now
how can people sat on their sofas sat in
places where they've never seen a
manatee help
you well they can help us first of all
by staying in farm
you can follow us um on instagram you
can look up
because clearwater marine aquarium um
there are many different ways of how you
can get involved with a different
project you can support you can fund you
can
you can volunteer accountability and
volunteer and assist
we've got volunteers coming from all
over the world you're welcome to believe
to assist with our efforts
you can share our effort you can join
another cause you can protect your
environment that you live in and
most of all follow our work and stay in
tune that way you can know what's
happening and what and you can find ways
that you can be
a part of our effort um we are always
posting on social media
clearwater marine aquarium you can visit
us at seawinter.org
to follow our great work across the
world including in belize
fantastic stuff and you're obviously
kind of very inspirational
very passionate and very dedicated and i
think that's what conservation really
really needs um
we've got more questions coming in but
jamal i'm counting on you to bring us
one more manatee before the end of this
live no biggie but
um you've got about five minutes i know
we have we have our hands on dick
everybody's looking right now including
myself
the balls on the water um okay another
question uh do you track all the
manatees in your area great question
we don't trap all of them in our era
since 1996 we've we've
actually handled a hundred and eight in
elementary so a hundred and eighty
nineties you've done health checks on
each one of these that we've handled are
are we put a pit tug in your neck
like you put in dogs say if it dies you
know who it is if you catch it again you
know who it is
but we haven't caught all elements in
our areas and
the areas that we normally do truck
managers are areas that are presenting
the highest traits
so we can so we can understand how these
trips are impacting the animals we don't
we don't
catch um antagonists in areas that don't
have threats
so it's only the heroes that are
massively developed heavily trafficked
and causing serious impact to their
species
otherwise i guess you would have no real
reason to track them um
yeah that totally makes sense um and
and your day-to-day if you could kind of
describe your
day-to-day or yeah i mean after this
what will you be going
to do going through the mangroves going
to see manatees what's your day
my day today my days are very difficult
my days are very difficult to plan
and that's the best part of my best part
of my job waking up not doing what i'm
going to do tomorrow
because i can end up in another part of
the another part of the country being a
rescue
i can be taken off of this manatee i can
be in a school talking to three-year-old
i can be in university talking to
university students
i can be at a public event giving a talk
so for me i have the best of
all because i can be in the office i can
be in the field but my idea today
always involvement and this even on my
day off because i spend time talking
about when i'm this when i go to the
market when i go to
dinner i meet someone that wants to talk
about my aunties and i never turn
anybody down i'm always
if this isn't if they're listening
fantastic um and just to kind of finish
up jamal is there anything else that
that you would like
everyone watching to take away from this
what do you want your research and your
your uh role with humanity conservation
to to tell others
not not just someone on this but we're
living in some telling time some
troubling times and people need to
really wake up and see the problems that
we are facing particularly the
environmental problems not just someone
entered
the world and other species and we all
have a part to play in ensuring that
these other mothers survive and our
environment is safe
be reminded that this is where we live
this is our home not just for wildlife
but our home
who doesn't want to protect their home
that's little chris but i encourage you
to be a part of conservation and we
encourage you to be a part of supporting
this effort
and i encourage you to follow all work
in belize and to follow our
our efforts globally um by following the
clearwater marine aquarium staying tuned
standing farm
participate share information and social
media so that the world can see
i've told you stories i've told you
about when i know it's your turn to go
and tell those stories to your friends
your family members
and let people in people across the
globe know when aunties in belize and
know what air force in belize
and i'd be surprised that i meet someone
from this life in belize volunteering
with me one day
yes i'm sure you'll be flooded with them
now well i hope so and
i'll be there included
i tell you this has been an absolute joy
um any more i do
out with another manatee hey i mean
we've had one i'm just being a little
bit greedy i think
um you know they're sort of looking
hoping that it's so wrong
i guess it's equally important to
remember that this is wildlife this is
uh completely wild manatees you know it
does what it wants
that's absolutely fine with me jawah
you've been a real joy to chat to you
thank you ever so much for coming to us
live
from belize um absolutely loved it it's
wonderful
it's a pleasure it's a pleasure and
we're happy to we're happy to be here
with you guys on the showcase belize but
he
has many many different wonders where
we're considered to be mother nature's
best kept secret and the only way he is
there you go go and support jamal go and
support work of the police manatee
conservation programme
and learn all about them what you can do
to help manatees
if you don't know much about manatees go
and learn more about them you know
they're such a vital species for
our ecosystems and they're fantastic and
so again a massive thanks to jamal for
tuning in a massive thanks to all of you
as well
for joining i hope you you enjoyed it
and you've got that glimpse of that
beautiful manatee
there from the red mangroves of belize
and we'll see you again next week at the
same time
for another meet the expert see you
later bye